so we have listed here are two
significant properties of indefinite
integrals and we will see in the future
that they are very very powerful all
this is saying is the indefinite
integral of the sum of two different
functions is equal to
the sum
of the indefinite integral of each of
those functions
this one right over here says the
indefinite integral of a constant that's
not going to be a function of x of a
constant times f of x is the same thing
as the constant times the indefinite
integral of f of x so one way to think
about it is we took the constant out of
the integral which we'll see in the
future both of these are very useful
techniques
now if you're satisfied with them as
they are written then that's fine you
can move on if you want a little bit of
a proof what i'm going to do here to
give an argument for why this is true is
use the derivative properties take the
derivative of both sides and see that
the equality holds
once we get rid of the integrals so
let's do that
let's take the derivative with respect
to x
of both sides of this derivative
with respect to x
the left side here well this will just
become
whatever's inside of the indefinite
integral this will just become
f
x plus g of x
plus
g of x
now what would this become
well we could just go to our derivative
properties the derivative of the sum of
two things that's just the same thing as
the sum of the derivatives
so this will be a little bit lengthy so
this is going to be the derivative with
respect to x of this first part
plus the derivative with respect to x
of this second part
and so this first part is the integral
of f of x dx we're going to add it and
then this is the integral of g of x dx
and so let me write it down this is f of
x
and then this is
g of x
now what are these things well these
things let me just write this equal sign
right over here so in the end this is
going to be equal to the derivative of
this with respect to x is just going to
be
f of x
and then the derivative with respect to
here is just going to be
g of x
and this is obviously true so now let's
tackle this well let's just do the same
thing let's take the derivative of both
sides
so the derivative with respect to x
of that
and the derivative with respect to x of
that
so the left-hand side will clearly
become c
times
f of x
the right hand side
is going to become
well we know from our derivative
properties the derivative of a constant
times something is the same thing as the
constant times the derivative
of that something
so then we have the integral indefinite
integral of f of x dx
and then this thing is just going to be
f of x so this is all going to be equal
to
c
times f of x
so once again you can see that the
equality clearly holds so hopefully this
makes you feel good that those
properties are true but the more
important thing is that you know when to
use it so for example if i were to take
the integral of let's say
x squared
plus
cosine of x the indefinite integral of
that
we now know is going to be useful in the
future say well this is the same thing
as the integral of x squared dx plus the
integral of cosine of x dx
so this is the same thing as that
plus
that
and then you can separately evaluate
them and this is helpful because we know
that if we are trying to figure out
the integral
of let's say pi
times
sine
of x
dx
that we can take this constant out pi is
in no way dependent on x it's just going
to stay being equal to pi so we can take
it out and that is going to be equal to
pi
times
the integral
of sine of x two very useful properties
and hopefully you feel a lot better
about them both now